what's the best part of this chapter and
you know being married to Ben there's so
many things I mean I I couldn't you
don't have enough time right now
well give me one oh look at that that's
that's a good that's a good version
no I gotcha I I hear you let me tell you
about my relationship with this I was
gonna say what give me that there you go
Josh
have you ever met him in person I have
he's a beautiful man he's dreaming
listen I'm gonna give that to y'all
that's good I'm not gonna see her
husband's dreamy because I don't want no
problems
don't get on my bad side
that dress is growing on me I wanted
something less traditional so marry me
shotgun wedding a real wedding it really
actually feels like you've been immersed
in all things bribe for like the past
years do you feel that way I do too I do
too I mean I didn't plan any of it this
way it's exciting and I find the movies
to be very different you know this is
kind of an action comedy romance comedy
so they're they're very different and
I've never done one like this so I'm
excited for people to see it because it
is very guys like I had to get my inner
Lucille Ball on for this you know what I
mean it was kind of more High jinxy more
kind of Broad and and uh the action
added a whole other element to it me and
Josh I mean I I couldn't have gotten
luckier to have the most amazing leading
man who could do the comedy do the
action and really you know nail the
emotional stuff and because we always
said in which Josh reminded me it was
like on our first call that we did it
was like if this people don't believe us
together none of this works if they
don't believe that these two really have
you know deep feelings for each other I
want to spend the rest of their lives
together and that falls apart like the
whole movie doesn't work and so it was
uh ever one of those things where
everything came together hello Mom now
is not the time I just want to ask is
that genetics or is it like Pilates she
really is having a moment uh Jennifer
Coolidge what is it like working with
her I've been watching her forever so
for me for her to be playing My Mother
by the way she's like nine years older
than me so it doesn't really make sense
that she's my mother and I just I'm a
huge fan she is a a wonderful person to
have around the set she's very chill and
what I'll never forget about working
with Jennifer was that you didn't know
if she was like messing up on purpose or
if it was like part of her thing exactly
is this it's almost like an Andy Kaufman
thing where you everything feels awkward
like what just happened and then you see
you're like is she intending to be funny
or yeah she'll be really lost right now
and it makes everybody feel like wait
you need another take she's like no I'm
good
I see it it is brilliant yeah absolutely
you know it's it's one of those it's one
of she's one of those enigmas yeah
[Music]